[Música]
una gran explosión destruyó en la mañana
de esta navidad varios edificios en el
centro de nashville tennessee en eeuu
en el acto intencional de acuerdo con la
policía resultaron tres personas heridas
y se encontraron posibles restos humanos
la explosión provino de un vehículo que
alertaba sobre una bomba lo que permitió
la evacuación de la zona la nueva cepa
del virus que se originó en el reino
unido- fue detectada en francia japón y
en el líbano los viajeros procedentes de
londres fueron puestos en aislamiento
mientras las autoridades niponas
prohibieron la entrada de todos los
vuelos de inglaterra y sudáfrica
alrededor de 9 países presentan casos de
la nueva cepa que según expertos el 70%
más contagios a los duros por rebeldes
en la república centroafricana cancelan
el cese del fuego de 72 horas previo a
las elecciones del domingo la coalición
opositora en la que se han agrupado seis
de los principales grupos armados
decidió romper la tregua ha anunciado un
día antes luego de que el gobierno se
negara a posponer los comicios en los
que participe el actual jefe de estado
hola como estan saludamos con gusto a
todos ustedes que nos siguen por la
señal de france24
soy alan austria sean bienvenidos
empezamos en eeuu una autocaravana con
una bomba se acudió a primera hora del
viernes el centro de la ciudad de
nashville dejando tres heridos leves y
cuantiosos daños materiales la explosión
se produjo minutos después de que el
propio vehículo emitiera un mensaje
alertando de una bomba por lo que la
policía local tuvo tiempo de evacuar a
los vecinos del sector ahora las
autoridades analizan un pañuelo donde
podrían encontrarse restos humanos que
darían mayores luces a la investigación
vamos a este informe de marina sardina
un cúmulo de escombros y calles
desiertas en el centro de nashville
capital del estado sureño de tennessee
en eeuu durante la mañana de navidad una
gran explosión sacudió el corazón del
ocio de la ciudad minutos antes del
estallido de una autocaravana bomba el
vehículo comenzó a transmitir un
escalofriante mensaje pregrabado
alertando de la detonación la policía
habla de un acto intencional que deja
tres heridos leves esta mañana alrededor
de las cinco y treinta los oficiales
respondieron a una llamada por disparos
en el centro de la ciudad de red
mientras los oficiales respondían se
encontraron con una autocaravana que
tenía una grabación diciendo que una
potencial bomba detonaría en 15 minutos
generales luego de la advertencia los
agentes se apresuraron a evacuar a los
vecinos de la zona pero la explosión
causó daños estructurales en varios
edificios y la onda expansiva derribó
también árboles y rompió ventanas a
cientos de metros
un oficial también resultó levemente
herido el fbi está dirigiendo la
investigación como un posible acto de
terrorismo mientras avanzaban las
pesquisas la policía local anunció que
habían encontrados posibles restos
humanos en las inmediaciones de la
explosión
no está claro si corresponden al autor
del ataque oa una víctima de week hemos
encontrado un pañuelo que podría
contener restos humanos tenemos que
examinarlo e informaremos sobre esto de
chinautla mercado de la autocaravana
quedó totalmente incinerada así que si
había alguien dentro no tenemos idea fue
una gran explosión pero las
investigaciones siguen en curso en toda
la zona seguiremos examinando si hay
restos humanos jeter y adhesión lines la
administración federal de aviación
suspendió temporalmente todos los desde
nashville debido a fallos en las
telecomunicaciones asociadas a la
explosión mientras la cruz roja local
está brindando refugio a los vecinos
desalojados la nueva cepa del corona
virus originada en el reino unido se
detectó ya en francia japón y en el
líbano el ministerio de salud francés
informó de un caso en la ciudad de tuc
de un viajero procedente desde londres
el pasado 19 de diciembre un caso
similar a lo ocurrido en el líbano
mientras que el ministerio de salud
japonés informó la detección en cinco
pasajeros procedentes del reino unido en
un vuelo del 21 de diciembre
y desde ayer hemos reforzado las medidas
para los extranjeros que han visitado el
reino unido al prohibirles la entrada
también hemos decidido tomar las mismas
medidas para los extranjeros que han
permanecido en sudáfrica y les hemos
prohibido la entrada a nota mente o
avión
murcia la coalición de patriotas por el
cambio en la que se han agrupado seis de
los principales grupos armados de la
república centroafricana decidió este
viernes romper la tregua ha anunciado un
día antes luego de que el gobierno se
negara a aceptar la propuesta de
posponer las elecciones generales del
domingo en la que 1,8 millones de
personas están llamadas a las urnas para
elegir presidente y 148 diputados adán
díaz nos informa más sobre estos
comicios
un proceso democrático en tiempos de
conflicto los principales grupos
rebeldes lanzaron una ofensiva armada en
las semanas previas a los comicios para
exigirle al actual presidente y favorito
en los comicios
faustina chanthu a derá que aplace las
elecciones pero la posición de las
naciones unidas- es firme y el organismo
cree que las elecciones han de
realizarse el 27 de diciembre y condena
por supuesto los intentos de grupos
armados de prevenir que el país progrese
democráticamente
[Música]
y es que retrasar los comicios
significaría un triunfo simbólico para
el exmandatario françois bozizé de quien
fue derrocado en 2013 dando inicio a una
guerra civil que se extendió hasta 2014
actualmente la coalición insurgente
controla dos tercios de la nación y no
se puede desarrollar un país mediante la
guerra de dos si hay problemas las
partes deben sentarse y discutir los
bien esas negociaciones cada formación
acuerda ganar pero también perder
la gente solo quiere paz parar en seco
un derramamiento de sangre que ya ha
dejado miles de muertos y más de 675.000
centroafricanos refugiados en países
colindantes
tras el acuerdo con el reino unido- los
gobiernos de los 27 países de la unión
europea revisan las 1246 páginas del
texto antes de su aplicación provisional
el bloque espera aprobarlo la próxima
semana a la espera de la ratificación
definitiva del parlamento europeo a
principios del 2021 ya sea si estaban a
favor o no del break city muchos han
expresado alivio aunque el texto del
pacto aún no ha sido publicado veamos
algunas de las reacciones para algunos
británicos este es un regalo navideño
incluso si no votaron para dejar el
bloque ciertos londinenses dicen que
están aliviados con el acuerdo que
finalmente alcanzaron la unión europea y
reino unido- tras 10 meses de intensas
negociaciones
preferiría permanecer en el bloque pero
me tranquiliza que esto haya terminado y
ahora el debate se acabó necesitamos
continuar en el silicon de cierto modo
plantea la pregunta sobre si el acuerdo
va a ser mejor que lo que teníamos antes
de que dejemos la unión europea
el texto del acuerdo aún no ha sido
publicado pero el primer ministro boris
johnson dijo que era un buen trato para
toda europa y sintió lo que significa
que ambas partes evitaron un final
caótico el proceso del éxito y los
negocios no enfrentarán aranceles a los
bienes que atraviesen el canal
en francia la sociedad está dividida
sobre este divorcio creo que está bien y
creo que francia debería hacerlo mis
padres
los británicos se darán cuenta que no es
una situación viable económicamente y
contrario a su pensamiento de querer
irse cambiarán de opinión
en escocia donde la mayoría votó para
quedarse en la unión europea el llamado
independentista persiste personalmente
preferiría que escocia sea parte de
europa así que esa es la forma en la que
votaré votaré por la independencia y
para que de escocia vuelva a ser parte
de la unión europea tanto los
parlamentos europeos y británicos tienen
que ratificar el pacto antes de que
reino unido se divorció del bloque el
primero de mirón
el líder de la oposición de malí y su
mala así se murió a la edad de 71 años
en parís a dos meses después de ser
liberado de un largo cautiverio por
insurgentes islamistas según confirmaron
fuentes familiares y de su partido si se
había ingresado en un centro médico en
francia después de que su estado de
salud
empeorará tras ser diagnosticado con
kobe 19
en otros temas con medias de aislamiento
del mundo cristiano celebro la noche de
navidad en los templos se llevaron a
cabo ceremonias con mínima de asistencia
en muchos sitios se mantuvieron algunas
tradiciones como en la plaza roja de
moscú que con protocolos de seguridad se
tornó blanca pues la nieve cubrió la
capital rusa donde la navidad a menudo
se considera una fiesta religiosa
únicamente pues la iglesia ortodoxa rusa
la celebra el 7 de enero
y precisamente en su mensaje de navidad
del papá francisco llamó a una
repartición justa de la vacuna contra el
cob y 19 este año el papá francisco
entregó su mensaje tradicional urbi et
orbi virtualmente y pidió a los líderes
políticos y empresariales no permitir
que las fuerzas del mercado y las leyes
de patentes tengan prioridad sobre hacer
que las fórmulas contra el kobe 19 estén
disponibles para todos condenando así el
nacionalismo y el virus del
individualismo radical como si nuestro
tiempo de oscuridad uncharted será la
pandemia apoyo en este tiempo de
oscuridad de incertidumbre por la
pandemia aparecen diferentes luces de
esperanza como el descubrimiento de la
vacuna pero para que estas luces
iluminen y traigan esperanza a toda la
humanidad tienen que estar disponibles
para todas las disposiciones de u2
muchas gracias a nosotros en francés 24
[Música]